c'est un homme que j'ai connus lors d'un
de mes voyages en extrêmement pur sucre
ça va être extraordinaire de connaître
des personnages aregno cela dit ses amis
prétendait qu'il avait toujours les
pieds sales après pourquoi parce qu'il
l'avait ainsi gros ventre qu'il prenait
des douches sans se mouiller les pieds
attendez attendez le plus beau c'est
qu'ils s'en rendent même pas compte
puisqu'ils ne pouvaient plus les voir
ses pieds ça c'est une blague mais ce
sont les tuer
elle est très bonne même nom mais non
mais écoutez moi est ce que ça ne serait
pas une allusion à ma forme physique en
eux pas de tout faire les pas du tout
jamais les de la nuit je pensais des
immigrants qu'est-ce que ça aide à
françois ouimet qu'est ce qui t'arrive
est-ce que j'ai les pieds propres est-ce
que tu allais eh bien oui apparemment
oui ça va mais pourquoi as tu oublié de
te laver ce matin non non mais je pense
être comme la mise à deux motions du
snob qu'il admire et bien il a un ami
qui a pas si gros ventre que lorsqu'il
prend une douche habré eh bien ces
petits ne sont pas mouillés
elle reste aux salles à eux et kazimierz
comprends tu as si gros ventre que tu
n'arrive même plus à voir tes pieds
est-ce que tu as pris une douche ce
matin non j'ai pris un bain de pieds
mais voilà pourquoi t'inquiéter à rabat
oui c'est vrai oui j'oubliais là la
différence entre une douche ou l'eau
varie par en haut et à bali où elle
reste en bas alors ça va casimir
bonjour là bonjour julie mais dis-moi
quasi
tu avais pas d grossi ces derniers temps
que justement nous étions en train d'en
parler figure toi que casimir n'arrive
même plus à voir c'est pire
c'est vrai qu'à finir bon faut faire
quelque chose
ce qu'ils vont faire c'est du sport tu
crois ah bah oui le sport et faire du
sport local alors au bout je suis pas
moi tu nous tiens et c'est le football
mais non ça ne sont pas impossible pour
moi pourquoi qu'est ce qu'ils t'ont
n'empêche mais justement parce que je
n'arrive plus à voir mes pieds
ah bah oui oui excusez moi casimir je
n'ai pas pensé ça existe
locke tennis jeu bah oui mais j'ai les
bras un peu trop court et bien et c'est
le ski très bon sport c'est une bonne
idée ça non non une très mauvaise idée
et pourquoi que du mur que ce qu'ils ont
mais parce qu'il n'y a jamais donné
jeudi l'otan portent à yvin à prier je
n'ai pas pensé à ça si tu essayais la
bvk ah oui la pop mais je me suis déjà
battue avec monsieur du snob et je t'ai
mis ko alors ces pressions bientôt
vraiment de parler d'amour effectifs
qu'elles signent les pythons train du
bouquet un certain max 2 devant quoi
bien c'est à dire que casimir se sont un
peu gros et nous étions en train de nous
demander quel sport il pourrait bien
pratiquée afin de retrouver sa forme
habituelle très bien c'est très simple
qu'il fasse de la course à pied très
bonne idée sur la course à pied et je
trouve aussi qu'est ce que tu en penses
oui je ne vont pas avec qui je pourrais
faire une course
je suis un bâtard et bien
moi casimir je te lance un défi sur un
kilomètre
c'est à dire 1000 m pourquoi je savais
ça fait très long et km de course ma
très chère julie il faut au moins cela
pour que la classe pas trop vous
laisserai prendre un peu d'avancé ajouté
monsieur je rentrais calmez vous et bien
la cour sera du tout à l'heure ici même
sur un kilomètre
allez vous préparer pour d'accord
messieurs vous êtes pas les attentions
au départ la course se fait sur un
kilomètre
c'est à dire deux tours de circuit près
absolument pas
[Applaudissements]
j'espère que vous leur avez bien tracer
le parcours en pur sucre
il ne risque pas de se perdre ils
descendent le long du petit bois
il tourne autour de la fontaine qui est
au bout de jardin et il passe près du
grand portail et bien alors ils
reviennent par le parlement ce que ça
donne très loin tout faux km 3 km pas
plus pour françois c'est pas gentil chat
vous vous moquez de les petites manies
ne nous vous vexez pas facteur rats je
vais pas dire ça pour me moquer de vous
je ne me vexe pas vraiment mais enfin
[Applaudissements]
camus
j'ai vu monsieur duchesneau avec
toujours en tête mais casimir s'accroche
mais il est toujours derrière
pour sûr que jamais que casimir capable
de courir ici j'aime vraiment s'il en
est et casimir est derrière nous il ne
se retourne jamais dit quand même quand
on voit des athlètes pareil et bah ça ça
vous donne envie de faire du sport mais
tant la wii les trois facteurs vous être
certain d'avoir calculé la distance
exacte à quoi un kilomètre 1000 mètres
si vous préférez pas un de plus pas loin
alors il était plus facile
un appétit mais que dire est-ce que du
logement c'est sérieux je tape aussi
rouleaux de réglisse tu tues réglisse tu
ne pouvait en trouver que dans le
kiosque
pourtant en lecture ce n'est pas dans le
parcours ah bon mais dillon casimir j'ai
tout compris
tu as triché pendant que monsieur du
snob lui faut c'est de retour toi tu
t'es dit que cacher derrière le casque
je sais que c'est pas mal de temps par
casimir déclassé et bleu du shop est
déclaré vainqueur
voilà bravo messieurs 10 nov passez-vous
le vainqueur oui casimir avait triché
vous félicite pas vous devez être
content à pour une belle course
c'était une belle tête
[Musique]